hello everyone and welcome to the tie
breaks of round five of the 2021 video
world cup it's andreas pink vs magnus
carlsen and
this is the last game of their match and
this is game eight yes they've played
eight games in this tournament
uh so first they played two classical
games which were very very equal the two
classic games ended in a draw then they
played two longer
rapid games which also ended in a draw
and then when they started the shorter
rapid games magnus started off with a
win and it looked like everything was
going his way but then espenko bounced
back with a win in the shorter rapid
time format and now we are in the blitz
section so magnus won the first blitz
game
it was a really really crazy game some
90 moves but in the end you know
everything was just flying over the
border you know they were both very low
on time
uh magnus was able to emerge victorious
uh in there
and now esipenko needs a win uh to get
back and magnus in in the blade section
and force armageddon so let's see what
happened here
this is game eight of their match so
acipenko with the white pieces
opens with e4 uh we have e5 by magnus
knight f3
knight to c6 and now bishop to c4 is
penguin now going for the italian game
bishop to c5 and now
uh not going for the evans gambit i know
you guys were wondering about that but
rather c3 the main line of the joko
piano
knight to f6 and now d3 so this is all
very very standard stuff we have d6
castles and h6 now
uh we have rook to e1 uh magnus castles
and
now h3 so both players just playing some
uh very very useful moves a6 a4
and now bishop back to a7 so later on
you don't have to worry about the b4
coming with
with tempo or d4 for that matter uh we
have knight b to d2 going for the
standard setup
maybe in knight to f1 to e3 maybe to g3
the bishop is coming to e3 later on we
have rook to e8
and now b4 so this has all been played
many many times nothing out of the
ordinary here
bishop to e6 and now we have captures on
e6 magnus captures with the rook
and now queen to c2 and this is
following
a very very famous game that was played
not so long ago
uh queen the d7 preparing to bring the
other rook into the game
uh and now knight to f1 preparing bishop
to e3 to trade off
black's very strong dark square bishop
on e7 on a7
uh we have d5 as white allowed it and
now
bishop to e3 we have captures captures
uh and now knight to e7 and here
uh there is a game that i've mentioned
and it was played by none other than
wesley so versus magnus cross and so
magnus already had this position with
the black pieces
and something is pink would definitely
prepared for if he went straight for
this line and he really really played
played it fast uh but magnus lost
this game in the gold money asian rapid
to wesley so that was played
not so long ago but in the game wesley
played the c4
uh so this uh posed some problems for
magnus but here we have rook eight to b1
and it is only now as of most 17 that we
have a completely new
game so is he penko uh you know uh
keeping uh the best for the end and now
this is what he's using to to get back
at magnus
we rook to d8 by magnus and now a5 so
grabbing more space here on the queen
side and later on you're gonna
of course uh continue expanding with c4
we have
knight to g6 and magnus is now bringing
the knight over to f4 and
now c4 we have c6 here you you either
capture or you play c6 you don't want to
play d4 because then
let's say knight to 5 and white has now
a lot of pressure on the king side and
also white it basically decides what
what's happening on the queen side
so magnus just strengthens his center he
plays c6 with rook e to d1
aligning the rook nicely with the queen
here and now knight to f4 by magnus with
knights to f5
uh and here the the knight is on a very
very unpleasant square
uh much like carlson's knight on f4 and
here carlson plays a beautiful move and
that is
g6 he says all right you can grab a pawn
you need a win in this game and you're
not going to win by playing
safe so you you have to grab a pawn and
you know make
make the best of it and now you have to
decide whether you're going to go back
or you're going to go after the pawn
so is pencil needing a win of course it
goes after the pawn but this also means
that now magnus will play king g7
and bring his rooks over to the h file
to be used for attacking purposes
uh we are king to g7 now attacking the
knight and here is pinko already uh
plays imperso
imprecisely he goes back knight to g4
here you have to continue in in great
style with knight captures on f7
queen captures maybe knight g5 attacking
the queen and the rook
and it's uh well it's a better position
for black
that goes without saying uh but if you
already went for the pawn grab then you
then you continue with this but here we
have knights to g4
and now magnus captures knight captors h
captures and here
uh magnus is in fact already winning but
it's uh
not uh so easy to see why at least for
them uh who are uh
playing uh you know five minute blitz
games uh but you are
you know comfortable in your own homes
uh i hope uh
watching this video so feel free to
pause the video here and try to find the
winning idea for magnus while i give you
a couple of seconds
so uh for those of you who are able to
do it congratulations on spotting this
not your everyday idea
and for those of you who just want to
enjoy the show it's captures on e4
yes the captures on e4 not the move you
first uh consider because well
the rook is eyeing the queen here the
thing is after d
captures an e4 now we play rook to d6
and look at this now we're threatening
rook captures on d1 but also queen
captures on g4
and that's gonna come with checkmate so
here white kind of has to trade we have
captures captures
or already not captures after white
capture so we're still gonna capture on
g4
uh threaten checkmate and now white has
to defend this white will play something
like knight to the e1 we're going to
play rook captures on v6
and now black has a winning position uh
without all that much counter play for
white so this
uh if you found it truly congratulations
that the captures on e4
was not an easy move to find but in the
actual game
magnus went back rook to e8 and now we
have
knight to h2 adding the defender here to
the g4 pawn
we have rooked the h8 even considering
something like
rook captures them bringing the other
rook over to h8 but
now we have f3 guarding this uh g4 pawn
so
magnus cannot grab it with his queen we
have d captures an e for
d captures and queen to e7 now preparing
to bring the queen over to h4
uh and now comes rook captures on d8 so
we trade off a pair of rooks queen
capture still keeping this idea alive
and now g3 and g3 although
uh a good move it's not the best one the
best move here is uh
in fact queen to b2 queen to b2 poses
a lot of problems for white and it's
it's a move that equalizes the game
uh now the problem is if you go queen to
h4 then we play queen captures on e5
and now you either lose the knight and
then we defend this night
or you have to go back but then we very
happily trade captures captures and we
are up two pawns of course now white
uh white is most likely winning this
so instead after queen captures on the
eighth uh queen like i said
queen to b2 was a really good move but
the g3 was played
and now comes queen to d4 check for
magnus
king to h1 you can't go king to f1 if
king to f1
then we just run you know you run into
rook captures on h2 queen captures and
now queen to d3 with
chuck connecting with the rook and
that's it king of two queen captures and
now of course we're we're completely
winning with black so after queen to d4
check we have king to h1 very unpleasant
because you
have to go you know in front of the rook
and now knight
to d3 so now magnus has some plans of
queen to e3 going for queen captures
on f3 as the knight is pin you will not
be able to capture back
so queen to e2 preventing this but not
just queen captures on c4 so
white kind of survived the attack but
now magnus will win a lot of material we
have rook to d1 going after the knight
here
but now rook to d8 and here we have
rook to f1 the rook can't really remain
here uh
if you try something like knight to f1
just knight f2 check and we win the game
there's no uh no no defending this the
king is in check you have to capture
and now we're going to capture on d1 and
win the game easily again we're up the
exchange
so after rook to d8 we have rook to f1
but now magnus just continues happily
grabbing uh
those queen side pawns with f4 uh e
captures g captures and now queen
captures on a5 there's even time for
that we have g5
now preparing f5 to bust open black's
king side
knight to c5 now we have queen to b2
with check and now king to g8 and now
knight to g4 going for knight to f6
check so magnus of course grabs the e4
pawn and guards the f6 square with his
knight but now
knights to h6 with check king to h7
and now queen to h2
uh trying to do some damage here with a
discovery or two
but magnus finds a very nice reputation
rook to d2 the queen of course uh
has the movie there are no discoveries
and you don't have a double check or
anything like that
so queen to h4 knocking the g7 getting
the king out of the way with
f5 uh white seemingly making some
progress
but it is not enough magnus simply plays
queen to d5
and now you really don't have a move
here black is threatening a lot of very
nasty discoveries
and if you move the king to the g1 it
really doesn't help just queen d4
checking h1 and knight f2
check and it's all over the king has
nowhere to go you can either go you know
in front of the rook or on the queen's
diagonal
or we're just going to capture the queen
here so there's really no move here for
white
so instead after queen to d5 we have f
this f6 with
check but now it's all the same magnus
just plays knight captures on f6
uh delivers a discovery uh from his
queen and he was in this position i know
43 that andre sipenko resigned the game
as there is nothing more to be done here
so as he lost the first blitz game now
he loses the second blizz game that
means
magnus is now at the winner and he will
go into round six of the of the video
world cup
uh so for those of you who are
interested uh i will
show the winners of the other rounds you
know if you're not interested if you
uh wanna you know keep it a secret or
something like that you know
feel free to um you know
maybe maybe end the video or maybe go to
some other parts of the video
uh but here uh you resign uh as there is
nothing more to be done here if king
juan queen you do checkmate and there
really isn't
anything else you can do here other than
you know uh giving start giving up
pieces for no reason
uh so yeah after knight captures on f6
that's it magnus wins and
these are the winners of the uh
of this round uh sorry not that sorry my
bad
these are the winners uh so carlson will
face
atm duda will face with it ferocious
will face tata
bay uh tabata bay and karakin will face
shankland uh sorry about that one uh so
it's gonna be
it's gonna be very very enjoyable we'll
see what happens and uh well
uh will will magnus finally be able to
to win defeated world cup as this is
one of the few tournaments that he still
uh has not
won uh so that's the game i hope you
guys enjoyed it
uh like i said this was a really really
incredible match and it's hard to you
know
showcase everything in one video but
feel free to check out the other games
uh
they were all really really awesome so
you know just enjoy
uh so once again i hope you guys enjoyed
it i would like to thank
michael j woodriding now kiara fazzini
hallback uh
john david kimura and thomas jenkins for
a contribution to my channel thank you a
lot i really appreciate it
as usual you can check to my previous
videos here thank you for watching and i
will see you soon
continuing the coverage of the video
world cup checking up on your wonderful
suggestions and whatever else happens
in the chess world thank you all i will
see you soon and have an excellent rest
of your day